that's my phone well here's the thing
about this okay there's two sides of the
table and it was on my side of the table
by law no there's one side of the table
it's a circle okay can't argue with that
math infallible back to the Julia
podcast are we gonna say anything
besides hello this episode hello
well for those of you that don't know
how that started it started on our
stream because I was just trying to
annoy Julian crying I kept popping into
the frame while he was playing and just
going hello hello and then all the chats
arguing hello and then the other night
on Twitter someone said hello to me they
tweeted at me so then it started an
incredible hello chain on Twitter no
it's just the whole thing we also hello
hello hello hello naturebox
is sponsoring the podcast and right now
you guys can get 50% off your first
start we're going to naturebox.com/tyler
julian that was not a say they have
amazing snacks over a hundred different
snacks guys always rotating in new ones
gluten free and vegan options dried
mango amazing snack okay
strawberry native fruit stars amazing
snack 50% off your first order right now
guys feel good about snacking go to
naturebox.com/tyler julian for
high-quality simple ingredients in your
snacks that are good for you
thank you nancy box thank you nature box
oh boy yeah hello have you had it no no
no honestly I don't even care that's
funny to me I'm like I'm so sleepy today
it's
and like I don't you ever know like we
didn't do anything crazy lot silently
I'm just so tired yeah for no reason
there's one thing today we didn't have
caffeine yeah sure and I think it
happens on the weekends more often where
we just like forget to caffeinate and
then we're just not acting their normal
selves I don't know if you guys have
that entire we've just been kind of
having a chill day we were watching some
twitch Jay Cyrus is doing some funny
things on Twitch
I hope my knees get dressed over
FaceTime and pick out her outfits for
the week yeah that was that was really
cute okay my sister-in-law is a genius
though because she was like it was
taking an hour every morning for her to
pick out her clothes so she bought like
a Tupperware drawer thing you know like
the the ones you get at like Target
where it's like plastic and container
yeah but it has drawers and so she
labeled them Monday through Friday and
on the weekends she has her go and pick
out what outfit so she wants so she
pulls a lot of her closet folds them and
puts them in the temporary drawers so
that she has her outfits all picked out
so that doesn't take an hour in the
morning that actually is pretty right
you're giving your your child autonomy
to pick out their own clothes but in a
way that does not make you furious in
the morning yeah brilliant it's smart
like that I like that were you allowed
to pick out your clothes when your kid
rollerskates and like a Batman outfit oh
you know what yeah the answer is yes I
was I was allowed to wear whatever I
wanted I did I wore roller skates for
like a whole year I was allowed to wear
what I wanted to but like my mom also
made us outfits she yeah no stitches
stuff all of our Halloween costumes
always homemade stuff yeah but my mom
would let us pick out clothes but I
stopped wearing dresses when I was like
two like I didn't like it I didn't want
to wear them I would only ever wear like
shorts and overalls and like
hand-me-down to my brother but when my
niece like really likes dresses she is a
cutie it's very cute yeah not me
what do you mean not you it translated
into me as an adult though like I don't
I don't [ __ ] with dresses you look good
in a dress huh I don't know I don't want
to are you look at them the only got a
dresses I really like are like
long maxi dresses well you basically
like you have a nightgown on but it's
shaped like something that society says
is okay it's a day nightgown what makes
it an icon just like how big it is just
how long it is and like flowy and you
don't wear anything but your underwear
underneath it right it's fun I'm you
down with that especially if it's hot
and you're like wow I've got breeze
coming from all directions all
directions all directions
not just one direction Oh Oh guys I
apologize already leave her for me Enya
I apologize I disappointed it you you
know alright what are you doing Julie
for a number of weeks now in the
comments there has been suggestions from
you guys suggested this yeah you guys
have suggested us to play a game called
snake oil it cures what ails ya it's a
party game you need more people to play
but we're not gonna do that yeah you
generally need like at least three but
you know what we don't listen to rules
here at the david.aileen podcast okay we
laugh at rules let me step on the rules
do we let me throw the rules in the
trash and then go get them cuz we
forever basically the game is about
making sales pitches to each other I
think people want to see us play this
cuz they want to hear you make up
[ __ ] maybe maybe possibly you're
pretty good at making up [ __ ] um so
look at the way the game works is one of
us is gonna be the customer and one of
us is gonna be the salesman the snake
oil salesman and the customer is gonna
have to draw one of these cards which is
a profession card
so it'll dictate what profession they
are and that will later force the
salesman to tailor their sales pitch
towards this profession then they say
the salesman picks out two random cards
and you put the two words together in
the cards and that's the item that you
have to sell so it's pretty
straightforward
I'm ready can I be the customer first
yeah so I just pick one of these yeah
are these like upside down or are there
two sides I think yeah we can just use
so why are these have I don't get it
those are blank I think your spacer
cards sorry I'll just pick on minis oh
boy I'm a cowboy let's sell me on some
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] cowboy
Wow cowboy you must have a lot of cowboy
friends don't you yeah you could say
that well I think in the cowboy
community it's it's important what belt
buckle you have yeah I think a lot of
them look exactly the same just a little
star a little silver star on your belt
bugger yeah yeah all your friends have
that but what's gonna set you a parking
another Silver Star is that what you
just want to blend in with all you come
over there do you want to you want to
step yourself outside the cowboy box and
be a better cowboy everyone else with a
rainbow star you will walk around your
cowboy friends at your cowboy rodeos
with a rainbow star so bright that they
can't even look at your belt his two
cards say rainbow and stars now tell me
you don't need that rainbow star for
your belt son so it's on a belt yeah
it's a rainbow star so whip like you
don't have to sell me a rainbow star you
you have to sell me you can make it
something else well I just said rainbow
star because that's the star is the
shape of the belt buckle anyway so it's
a rainbow star mm-hmm I want to read
those rules okay word cards I mean I'm
pretty sold I think you did a pretty
good job mm-hmm yeah all right well you
know my outfit colors they're usually
pretty neutral so you selling me on a
lot of color here here's what's gonna
happen
you buy the rainbow star and suddenly
every single outfit makes sense for
every single day so not only can you
wear all of your clothes at once and
they will all match your single ring or
you were nothing and the rainbow star
will have the shade of color that is
your skin and will match your outfit in
the rainbow in the rainbow the rainbow
has all colors I mean yeah okay I'm kind
of sold that you sold it to me in a belt
I was that was that's the greatest thing
about rainbow star it can be solved in a
belt it can be solved in a wall
it can be sold in a butt plug whatever
your thing is just it's rainbows if you
do not Julian so maybe just maybe not
the butt plug is just the regular belt
alright you did good
he's also sharp you can throw it at
people stabbed them right and I do bleed
but the blood will not be rainbow the
blood will be red no we sell weapons ok
all right there's no risk going I guess
we're just gonna do it just keep score
here you can keep that okay it means
that you sold it sold it to a cowboy
give me give me the card
I'm not gonna be as good at this as you
are
I am a hunter
okay Julian yes as a hunter have you
ever just gotten lost in the woods like
oh my god I have no idea where I am and
you know how to I lost a lot of funds to
get lost all the time in fact you know
and I know you're a good hunter your
skill time do you believe in your skills
but sometimes the hunt is only as good
as what's out there to hunt nothing to
do with you right yeah sometimes I'm out
there for hours and even days and I
don't hear a peep where I am well so in
case sometimes you're out there lost in
the woods you can't find anything to eat
you can't find anything to hunt let me
introduce you just pack this small and
compact vomit bush blade fit webbing you
make camp that night give it a little
bit of water and you wake up and it's
full of vomit like yeah maybe it's not
your first choice in terms of food but
since it's dried vomit in the beginning
and then you water it and it turns into
full wet vomit it's edible
even though it's kind of gross
nutritious delicious you can get lost in
the woods for up to two weeks at a time
with vomit bush so is the bush vomiting
and then I eat the vomit vomit the vomit
goes on the bush oh it's a gross it's
pre-made vomit so it's like a chia pet
do you have to start the vomit till I
get it going or will they vomit
everything itself no you just water it
in the vomit it doesn't have any
nutritional value honestly I don't care
I'll take it I'm not here right now
it'll keep you alive
in the vomit bush is it poisonous to eat
out of a bush doesn't sound a medical
professional how sure are you that I can
eat everything that grows on the vomit
house in person
that's an excessive percentage the vomit
bush was it tastes like vomit
like human vomit yeah does it look like
a human bomb is are you sure you're not
just vomiting the question selling it to
me I'm sure it's a chia pet for vomit
for survival dude sold I am so hungry
out there I never find food yeah we
gotta leave no I go hunting a suck okay
you ready
a six-hour drive outside my city to go
hunt I don't know why I do it oh I'm a
hostage you're a hostage let me tell you
something okay
you have limited time left on this
planet you don't know what's gonna
happen you say I'm gonna die you have
limit you've potentially limited time
you don't know if you're gonna get
killed by your captor you don't know if
you're gonna get transported off to
another place while being blindfolded
you don't know which means which means
which means you don't know when your
next meal will be okay and if I could I
would offer you naturebox but I don't
have naturebox to sell you all I have is
something that you might have on you
right now which is a belt do you have a
belt on you you do look I see it right
there imagine if you had bought the belt
candy you can be you could eat while you
were captured where are you ha see you
while you're captured at the bottom of a
basement for months and months and
months tortured and by a demented person
you could have eaten your belt candy
they would have taken my belt no it
looks like a belt they don't have a need
for about but to you it's candy
and you can survive off of it
no you wouldn't think you're slowly
withering away and starving down there
you take a little bite out of the bell
candy everyday you're getting stronger
and stronger until the last day when you
bite the buckle off the belt candy and
then you see the pile of clothes in the
corner he took my belt candy well they
eat the whole thing
before he can strip you naked just like
in your mouth is it a fruit by the foot
belt is that what you're saying stronger
strong stronger than that
leather and how can I eat it because the
leather is from candy cow what the [ __ ]
it's a cow made of candy it's the skin
of a cow made of candy
eat it what candy it's a combination
between gushers and mounds not salt
chocolate fruity gushy not sold it melts
in your hands
not Solon's down on your wrists not sold
you don't even know how you got here
anymore mouth candy LLC I'm selling you
my company it's called belt candy LLC
it's a production company has nothing to
do with belt candies do you like to buy
my production company no I don't want
your production company called belt
candy why not because one time we saw we
drove through Hollywood and saw a big
movie shoot we saw it that's how good we
are at both candy we saw it with our
eyes Yeah right it doesn't help me in my
hostage well you never know how how many
hours are gonna be in the unit need some
entertainment Bell candy will produce
high-quality entertainment it's going my
iPad I need you to buy this okay we're
not selling anything anyone I need this
no you need to understand what about
candy brings to the table nothing
you're a ride-sharing service we can
rescue you okay
you get on the belt candy apple in your
phone which is it's in beta right now
has
have been started to created but when
it's it when exist you go on the app
about candy about candy driver will be
there in two seconds what happened to
you being a belt candy company with
candy belts so that was just a
production company or a ride-sharing
service you need a ride don't you you're
cutting your gear hostage
no I need a policeman no candy up South
candies are actually undercover cops
we're selling you our protection
services about candy protection services
we are cops cops candy cars
buy our services a little cop for you
know why don't you want us we will serve
and protect and be about candy are you
still making movies out of your
production company that was all just a
front were undercover cops all these are
fake stories this is to help you get out
of hostage we invented this company belt
candy specifically to get you out of the
situation that you were in no one was
gonna let us anywhere if we told them
that we were a cop
we had to disguise as a production
company and then as a ride-sharing
service to get every step closer to you
and now we're here we only have 30
seconds left they're coming we need you
to get in the car we exist only for you
we respond like a character in a video
game for you to save you from the
hostage situation potentially dangerous
you okay we saved her we did it about
candy is now dissolved we are okay dude
we are cops honestly what happened is we
just needed to rescue you and I had to
come up with a hundred different reasons
to get past all security and we did it
happy to have you home son I'm gonna
take the hostage because I sold Oh
good I can't believe you got a point for
that
that's like actual garbage I am a
paparazzo okay
sell to me all right Julia so as a as a
threats of papa-paparazzi
buh-buh-buh-buh i'm your biggest fan
i'll follow you love me papa-paparazzi
stop singing me Lady Gaga so as a
paparazzo what's the difference between
paparazzi and paparazzo is that plural
and singular no it's our male and female
species no way paparazzi is female
paparazzo is female no way wait those
are both funeral what the hell no it's
paparazzi is plural paparazzo is
singular okay well else he knows no
gender after you take your pictures
right you you run around town you find
these celebrities you take their
pictures of them doing interesting
things yeah then it's time to get on the
horn and call up all the magazine's and
be like I got these pictures of this
person or sometimes the other way around
the horn where where the celebrity will
call and set up an appearance which
people still don't understand with it
like wow look at all these beautiful
pictures of someone so far looking on
the beach oh I can't believe just
paparazzi with it's cuz they [ __ ]
call them to show up and take pictures
close them no I always find it so funny
on the same people who complain about
kidding paparazzo bothering them they
post those pictures on their instagrams
you ever see that no I've seen the same
people who complain also repost okay no
people call paparazzi to show up and
talk to them and perpetuate the pay
attention to me whatever but cuz we're
actually not playing game right now this
this whole thing was just to explain to
you that that is the thing okay we want
you to know the truth paparazzo
sometimes is arranged by the person
themselves
though okay so after you take your
pictures of your celebrity a person you
whatever you doing and then you gotta
get on the horn you gotta call all the
news outlets and be like I got this
thingy pictures of this person doing
this stuff and you know depending on the
pictures that you got of them they might
be really really valuable but then
you're in a bidding war then it's like
oh my god and then you gotta get back
and forth on the phone calls Oh who's
gonna have them it's gotta get done
quickly cuz you just hook them in the
breaking photos I gotta get out now you
know I'm saying yeah but what if there
was a place for you to just simply
upload your pictures completely secure
and private to all of the news outlets
who could immediately bid like eBay on
who wants them for what and they could
pay you immediately I like that that
sounds easy and not cpgs just a photo
heaven then everyone gets the pity more
for me you don't have to do anything how
secure is it more of doing the things
that you love which is standing around
being in the party job you don't like
we're just selling them for a hard price
actually doing work so I have a question
how secure is photo heaven sounds really
really secure I'm talking experience
secure why is it called photo heaven
does that mean my photos are dead no
with anything it's just where you go to
upload your pictures do you have an app
for iPhone and Android of course we do
so good yes it is seamless beautiful see
if they're paid monthly you will listen
we designed photo heaven with paparazzo
angels listen we know that Y on the
beach in Tahiti following around gigi
hadid okay it's not like this is no
desktop this computer around there to be
exactly so you got a wirelessly upload
me pictures from me camera t-phone music
I fight and then you gotta use the
mobile app so we've designed it to be
very user friendly for people like you
on the beaches of Tahiti sweatin
following around Gigi Hadid who is at
least 45 years younger than you do you
have do you have to pay monthly as a
membership for the servers yes it's
about two dollars a month for you to use
and for the the websites it's about $15
a week just for me yeah for you is the
my getting a special price because
you're popped all right so okay um okay
good good amazing things that you love
like being in the way I was good that
was the best part of your sales pitch oh
thank you you're welcome
all right my turn grab it grab ah what's
the difference between the blue side and
the green side is there anything I
didn't read enough in instructions to
know that come on I think there's just
different cards I don't like that one
all right what is your profession I'm a
priest you know the definition of hard
work I do encouraging and motivating a
lot of people mm-hmm every Sunday that's
me at church yes sir a lot of people a
lot of people yeah Lots
but yeah what happens when it rains you
can't go to church when it rains because
it's impossible to get that no one's
trying them right it's a Sunday you got
Sunday drivers you got wet roads even in
the Lord's name you cannot make it to
church sometimes cuz the rain is too
crazy okay and when you're out in the
rain yeah you are thirsty you need to
drink water even though it's falling
everywhere which sounds kind of turn
when you the priests are trying to get
to church and it's pouring rain and you
grab your umbrella I
your parched yeah because waters around
you which means by osmosis it's leaving
your body and you need you need a refill
you need to refill umbrella water which
is a water bottle that goes through your
umbrella filters of water and and goes
up through a straw into your gullet well
your only works on Sundays if you're
going to church oh is it gonna help me
get to church sometimes you rushed okay
here's a lot and you park somewhere you
say [ __ ] I thought this is a lot of
closer to the church but it's far I
gotta run but it's pouring rain you need
umbrella water because when you run from
your car to the holy house you need high
drapes really bad you need to hydrate in
the rain you forget about the water cuz
it's all around you but what about what
goes down your mouth to be the highest
paid and performing priest ever you need
water
normal water does not work with
umbrellas it just beads off and gets
wasted and then goes down the gutter and
goes to Pennywise and no one's even
around you need water filters through
the umbrella it doesn't just protect you
from the rain it gives you the rain to
nourish yourself and your holy spirit on
the Sunday only rains on Sundays why
didn't you sell it to me that like we
could instead of buying our holy water
we could go outside collect it from
rainwater with them because I'm brother
water is not certified holy water you
cannot baptize people with umbrella one
it's a it stays in the umbrella
there's no spigot you put your mouth on
the umbrella and it goes you drink it
there's no getting it out of the
umbrella
there's through the umbrella water it's
a patented technology that we didn't
create we stole it from my friend the
water beads through the umbrella off and
instead of going out onto the ground it
comes back in and then rushes through
and gets filtered like a Brita it's my
own brother I don't need it we own Brita
this is Britta it's something you've
read up as a new church I know you have
a lot of management shifty management
breath okay by Brita Brita like five at
least depending on how many fridges your
church has these are the Neuwirth but
what is the umbrella have to do with
anything
umbrella water was that umbrella water
is the company that is under the same
umbrella as Brita that's why it's called
umbrella water I'm not letting you get
away with this second one I want you to
drink out of my bread I candy boat we
art no no you are like I hear in your
hearing your voice how thirsty you are
and we have the water we have the
hydration okay
every Sunday you're up there screaming
okay we make we make a podium a podium
that has a water fountain attached to it
that's Britta's new invention we haven't
really talked about it we can't release
it yet but while you're up there doing
your sermon is that what's called sermon
while you're doing the sermon and and
you're inspiring all these people on a
beautiful rainy Sunday you need to like
lean over your podium in just three
hands-free okay we have a motion sensor
water fountain install the podiums the
best of politicians use it and now we're
bring
it's a church and you were the first
priests we want to use it nothing is
more inspiring trust me I've seen it is
magical no no you're not gonna get away
there is nothing worse in church than
having to pause so the priest has to
take a sip of water out of the water
bottle like like like some sort of sort
of non special human he is a special
human he needs to drink hands-free it's
like that well he's I'll he's talking he
needs to stop what he's doing and he
needs to drink with umbrella water we
are creating a giant umbrella that goes
on top of churches and provides water to
the whole church production production
it's 40 feet tall this eco-friendly just
shake my hand okay we'll be done here
good good job on the last Sunday and
watch do you want the people of your
church to have water from the umbrella
and the ceilings come down to the seats
and have individual water fountains of
every seat in church did you want that
do you want them to the hydrating or not
it's necessary and you need it bring
their own water
we're not waste all of these plastic
bottles on this beautiful gorgeous earth
that we have you wouldn't have to
if you had umbrella water yourself a
dear sir well done sir great doing
business with you yes I'll visit you
next Sunday I'll be installing the
umbrella change it 20 times
the thing about snake oil okay is you
have to be crafty with your sales pitch
you have to be able to shift and jump
around and and move laterally while
you're selling because one direction
might not be working you need to jump
over and take the other angle that's
what it's about that's where I created
this game called snake oil guys and you
can buy it right now discontinued by
manufacturing calm really it actually is
discontinued by the manufacturer how did
you get it I pulled some strings here
and there you know I gotta UNPO skates
it was that at Toys R Us or something
alright
delivered it right to my house it was
amazing it's like nature barks when they
deliver it right to your house you not
to do anything every month does simple
ingredients no artificial flavors colors
or sweeteners delivered right to your
house every month or you can just buy
them one off doesn't matter okay you can
have a subscription service or you can
just buy them you know whatever you want
they have over 100 snacks that taste so
good and actually better for you guys I
know we all want to eat better but when
it comes to snacks they taste good
generally but they aren't good for you
that's where nature box comes in okay
you can feel good about what you're
eating right now
Jen and I are snacking on this
strawberry lemon-aid fruit star that we
still have we still have them they're
still in our cabinet and we also just
salt and pepper lentil loops are really
good those are a nice little savory
snack guys you'll you will definitely be
finding your new snack obsession at
nature box and like I said they're
constantly changing up their snack
options with the input inspired by the
latest trends of professional chefs guys
this is no joke like nature box has been
around they're thriving they have great
snacks all over the place okay head to
naturebox.com/tyler room right to your
door with no risk if you ever tried
snack you don't like guys you don't to
eat it okay naturebox is like all right
maybe
not for you okay maybe it's not for you
they'll replace it for free with this
knife you do like right now nature vlog
is giving you 50% off your first order
that's half off guys you can't say no to
that okay half off snacks we all have
snacks extra bucks accomplice Jenna
Julianne thank you and when you're
looking to get some holiday shopping
done probably for your dad or maybe your
brother Matt wife or maybe your sister
dad or maybe your daughter maybe your
steps are maybe your step granddaughter
whoever it is in your life that wants
something you want to get them a
movement watch because movement watches
look so nice and they are affordable
they look like they cost five six
hundred dollars no starting at $95 they
have really quality watches light
quality build we have some actually
ordering another one I'm ordering
another movement watch with my code okay
and with you can also get 15% off plus
free shipping if you use our code too
seriously guys it's MVM t okay the story
about how movement watch it started so
cool to broke college kids that wanted
to wear stylish watches but couldn't
afford them they made they were like hey
why don't we just make this a thing why
don't you make stylish good quality
looking watches okay but affordable all
right they only sell their products
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and mark the retail and mark
the reach and and the retail markups re
and then you get the best price for you
guys as possible when you're getting a
new watch
so they start at just 95 dollars
literally check it out right now and VMT
comm /jj and go look at their selection
because they have a whole bunch of
different style watches different bands
different watch faces it's like really
really cool the revolutionary pricing
along with movements classic design
quality construction and styled
minimalism has led to over 1 million
watches being sold in 160 countries it's
time for you to step your watch game up
or those in your life's watch game up
without them knowing Surprise them with
this ok good gift they will like it
I go to M VMT dot-com /jj get 15% off
today that's for you ding fam and you
get free shipping and also free returns
yeah thank you sponsors heyyou sponsors
are you ready good lord
pick an occupation alright I'm a
protester that was just on the top one
good try
I'm a beggar it's my profession okay
Julian what listen here okay for a lot
of reasons you've found yourself as a
baker right yes you stand on the corner
of the 405 or the sign that says food
it's a parking sign that you ripped off
the street no it says send nudes but
yeah I'll take food whatever there's a
lot of complicated reasons why you've
wound up having to Panhandle and
sometimes people give you like a dollar
here and a dollar there sometimes it's
enough for you to eat sometimes it isn't
mostly it's not yes a lot of a lot of
times you go to bed hungry and you're
just looking for shelter and you just
want some help don't help well wouldn't
it be nice if you could just walk over
to the prize River what do you think
work don't work so just reach in you dip
you in it and you blotter prize give me
an example of a prize yeah so think like
the dentist or the orthodontist or
something we pull out like a sticky hand
how's that gonna feed me in my family is
there anything of actual value in the
Preiser absolutely the whole river how
many acres does it spend the entire
weight so you you're saying the LA River
has been infested with prizes they're
worth a complete total of forty five
cents oh yeah they time we gotta races
we got squishy things bouncy balls
whatever you want
it's mostly charlie dumped it on us they
didn't want it anymore and we were like
we'll take it and fill up the river it's
a prize river I'm enticed but I have a
question when I reach in are
they are they just gonna be some wet and
sopping no there's no water it's dry
it's a prize river
it's just prizes no water just prizes
can you dive into it or will you hurt
yourself you can but it's frowned upon
because we don't want you to break the
prizes for other people know if look
you're talking about miles and miles of
miles of prizes yep
collective 45 cents how shitty are the
prizes okay maybe a little more than
that I was lying okay but like it's full
of prizes River so what are you selling
to me I can just I can just go do it
right now without buying anything from
you we gotta get exactly we got to get
people over there we got to get the word
out so that's all doing this is telling
me about the prize event so this just
like a PSA yep
no but there's nothing of use I need to
be fighting for my life to eat and drink
yeah but who doesn't like a sticky ends
the cans are pretty fun do you want a
kazoo I I want a kazoo do you put
vuvuzelas in the prize river yeah I'm
there give me the card yes vuvuzela
that's what got me ready yep what are
you laughing I'm just laughing what is
your profession miss I am actually an
alien Oh
the best kind of thing I would like to
personally just introduce myself
hi alien I like you because you're not a
human I'm a fan of people who are not
humans I love I don't know I don't know
where you come from planet hello maybe
Wow okay maybe shut up though try to
sell here sometimes when you go to your
alien meetings okay and you need to have
good alien ideas to impress her alien
friends and co-workers mm-hmm you don't
know what to do okay you can write down
all the ideas you want but at the end of
the day you walk to that meeting and you
got to just give him some gold or else
you're you're out of here mm-hmm you're
gonna be kicked off the alien ship
thrown all the way into space maybe
never found again may be found by a more
dominant alien species who's gonna
you know you know okay you need to have
you need to have yourself prepared going
into these meetings okay which means
inside of your pockets you cannot have
anything in there you need to clean out
your pockets so that you can fill it
with pocket fear you need pocket fear
inside of your pockets do you know what
pocket fear does pocket fear is not a
physical thing okay okay you buy it and
it's air and then you take the air and
you put it in your pocket that's pocket
fear what it does is it instills fear
into the eyes of Europe into the eyes of
everyone oh you pull out some pocket
fear and throw it at their [ __ ] face
and they are terrified of you and then
you automatically have the floor
everything you say goes because they are
terrified you have the pocket fear that
sounds like persuasion pocket persuasion
straight just give you a little example
okay how do you feel now scared I see it
in your eyes terrified in my pocket fear
I pulled it out and damn the moment
changed you were now scared of me and
are listening to everything I say there
was no pretending I did it everything
and you reacted to the pocket fear the
chemicals are reactive I don't feel
scared I feel like I want to get away
from you well it's pocket fear you need
pocket fear on your side because if it's
not on your side it's on my side I'm
gonna get you with it well I have a
question what happens if you have
pockets here and I have pocket fear I've
always seen that happen once
doesn't sound like anyone's gonna have
an advantage everyone bad everyone in
the room is dead now so why would I care
pocket is dangerous you need one person
needs to have pocket fear and so far you
are the only human weight your alien
you're the only alien I've ever sold to
so you'll probably be the only alien
with pocket fear how long does it last
twenty minutes okay no I know you have a
meeting soon you can go use it no
I don't want any pocket fear pocket fear
by it I don't wanna buy my pockets you
didn't sell me I don't need it I don't
want you to buy my pocket fear I don't
want it
pocket fears okay it's this new company
that we sell people were going to the
zoo and what it does is it elicits the
scent that makes all the animals scare
so they know don't take into your
pockets and take your bonus have you
ever been to the monkey Zoo a fool but I
know you have you have they go into your
pockets because your pockets did not
have pocket fear inside of them they
will take everything out of there they
will rob you for everything you have
sorry it says rocket fear okay no it
says rocket food no he doesn't it says
pockets here I got nothing I'm giving up
kids all [ __ ] pocket fear this is good
I'm a politician come on baby
all right you're a politician right yes
do you have what kind of politician are
you the kind that goddamn [ __ ] wins
yeah but like what kind of office do you
hold the highest so you're the president
I'm the president the president no I'm a
mayor you're mayor mayor okay so as a
mayor you probably have some security
but you don't have like Secret Service
right yeah they pretty much confound
everything yeah like you have you have
some people looking after you but like
if somebody wanted to attack you they
could in theory right I get attacked all
the time okay so basically what I'm
gonna be selling to you is your own
personal security device I like it for
the most dire of situation what is it
it's your knife so the way that it
engages is we surgically implant it into
your throat oh so when you yell the cold
word banana it comes shooting and yawn
it comes shooting out of you throw and
it stabs someone to death instantly on
the spot so once once I use it once can
I what will it be able to be used again
a drive to have the surgery again well
we you probably need a doctor to get it
back and you throat but you don't need
to have the surgery so it's just a
one-off thing what does that mean so if
I'm in danger mm-hmm I have to yawn what
if I can't yell you have to yell and
yawn and say banana that's a lot of
things at once well you know do you want
to die yeah and then it comes shooting
out it just comes out like that yeah and
then does it kill someone yeah am I
responsible for murder
yes what about your company where do you
guys get off what's your liability we
have nothing to do with anything you
just told me you're trying to sell it to
me no we give people nice this whole
meeting is being recorded I have
security in my mayor's office
look all we are is were yawn knife okay
so we're telling you that the technology
what if it goes off accidentally no I'm
taking my pet snake for a walk in
omelette and then BAM stabs my pet snake
who's responsible for that
mmm probably snake why what did he do
he's scary
he deserves to die yeah he's scared
that's it how much is it thousand
dollars 99 I like the way you look I
wanna buy it for you oh honey on knife
I'm just buying from you cuz you cute
there you promised oh come have dinner
at the mayor's office won't you can I do
one more in then we'll finish yeah all
right I'm gonna sell you I'm gonna sell
you good knife all right
last one guys we're tired what can I say
pick a profession I'm a diva you are a
diva let me tell you this you are a diva
okay you have so many fans out there you
are the most popular person that's ever
walked anywhere ever okay okay at least
in your own mind but in reality you
actually do have fans you are popular
mm-hmm you can't go to the mall without
getting mobbed and sometimes that's a
lot and sometimes when you get there you
realize a little too late that you're
stuck you're stuck they surround you and
sticky they're real sticky cuz they're
sweaty and they've been waiting around
for you they start sticking to each
other and then you see a little
semicircle forming and then it's a full
circle and then you're you're trapped
you cannot get through these fans you
need to get where you need to go but
there are fans full 360 full mosh pit
their mosh pitting now they're
everywhere you can't get anywhere
survive the physical space around you
has been consumed by your fans because
you are such a diva oh until now
you now have fan butter you put butter
all over your fans
you take fan butter everywhere you go
all of a sudden you just slip and slide
right between them you're the
slipperiest running back in the NFL you
no one can touch you wait so I put the
fan butter on me yeah it comes in spray
for him okay it looks like pepper spray
sore terrifies the [ __ ] out of everyone
but you just spray them and then it's
fan butter
okay so everyone's slippery now no one
can grab a hold of you they say hey Deva
I want a picture they go and then they
fallen probably hurt themselves really
really importantly but we can't we can't
we can that we have nothing to do with
that injury I actually feel like that's
that's a pretty good idea for crowd
control just making everything super
slippy yeah it's it's a imagine if you
basically you cover the floor in banana
peels
it's basically that scene in Zoolander
where they're having a gas fight that's
what it is except they don't all die at
the explosion will destroy little earth
they all died in that scene surf orange
mocha frappuccino you can have yourself
an butter
it actually looks just like a gas
gasoline hose
like it you just pull it out of your
purse you spray fan butter no one can
touch you that's not a bad sales pitch I
like I like that I think that's it's
pretty great right are we are we coming
sign yeah they said really yeah cuz you
didn't change the company twelve times
well there's fan butter but we also have
no sister no fan margarine okay no or
when they show up at your house and they
need breakfast
no you have fan margarine you can spray
them with margarine it's a fan that
sprays butter it's not for your fans
it's literally fan butter you turn on
the fan and it just sprays Barra
everywhere and then you have a scent of
butter everything's covered in butter
this is only if you love butter this is
basically just for REE Drummond we got
it yes he's just going on on the ranch
can we get her on for a [ __ ] podcast
did we get on for a podcast wish how do
we how do we get we German on the
podcast we should fly to her bring all
the podcast on the ranch podcast on
their ranch podcasts on the ranch she
went to like USC like she went to
college she married she's not yeah like
she's pretty rad she's got a pretty cool
life I feel like beat Bobby Flay in a
cooking competition I looked at her
Wikipedia page okay
I read stuff about REE Drummond hi I'm
REE Drummond here's what's going on on
the ranch I'm gonna pour 14 bars of
butter into the cereal bowl and then I'm
gonna eat it oh boy this game was fun
man this game is fun if you have a
Julianne in your life that loves to just
embellish the [ __ ] out of everything
yeah liking you too much I literally
almost got up and left when you were
doing that umbrella Church [ __ ] yeah
speaking of umbrella Church right now
guys know if you need to tell someone
something that no one else can find out
just get yourself an app get secret a
napkin secret you can write anything you
want on it
that's a napkin though it's a napkin
secret know the thing about a napkin
secret is once you write it down whoever
touches it dies
immediately it [ __ ] is laced in poison
no we're done we're done
Julian spit cheese you need spit cheese
because sometimes when you when you're
spitting on the ground it's just it's
just gonna dry up too fast you need to
Lee to leave some markings of cheese
that's disgusting
it's a can of cheese it doesn't just
cheese whiz it just spits it out what
you say cheddar Gruyere and it just
spits it out at you done we're done book
soap Julian who's gonna wash your books
you need to wash your books they're not
gonna wash itself they need to get
washed you need to get mopped
specifically but this is this is how you
do it it's with books up oh wait
urghhh so hope you guys enjoy this
podcast this is fun I like this game
maybe we'll do it again with a third it
might be fun with her yeah with more
people does that it's like cards against
humanity' but with more arguing yeah we
can also I think they gave us blank
cards to write some ends
yeah I'm pretty cool well thank y'all
for hanging out for another pound KS
yeah yeah yeah Bui we'll see you guys
next week for another one check out
seriously movement watches really
awesome stuff check out the links down
below in nature box and we'll be
probably live on Twitch all week so
let's see you guys there or something
alright
well not Tuesday night we're going to
the streamys pray for me yall I have
nothing to [ __ ] wear right do you
know I'm not wearing anything
yeah mowing I we like i legit don't have
some anyway we just didn't do it this
weekend we didn't go get something to
wear you're supposed to shop this week
and we not like fancy and have people
dress us we're supposed to get ourselves
clothes and we didn't do it
yeah ok I'll talk about it ok
[Music]